le plan d'eau du marin si calme que l'on
pourrait entendre une mouche voler ou
plutôt une yole passé mais cela pourrait
bien ne pas durer car dans moins de 48
heures sont attendus les premiers
concurrents de la militante that la
boulangère alors dans les différents
services de la commune comme ici à
l'office du tourisme c'est
l'effervescence
ce matin il s'agit de coller les
dernières affiches dans les lieux
stratégiques pour ceux qui ignoreraient
encore la venue de l'événement cette
semaine c'est la surprise nous on verra
cela en temps normal ça arrive à
l'arrivée de l'autre côté
donc on verrait que ce ça va nous donner
et si ça rapporte quelque chose vous
nous aimez la prochaine fois on va faire
revenir sur le bouton communal car en
effet pour cette édition l'arrivée était
déplacé au plus près du coeur de ville
tout juste en face du marché allant vers
aller comment ça va se mouiller sur le
passé avec les clients les gens qui
veulent bien que le public vous pensez y
aura du monde
[Musique]
gaston alba de raisons d'être content
d'accueillir la mini transat
la première c'est que depuis l'enfance
il est passionné de voile il y avait
huit ans il participe même à la
transquadra la seconde c'est qu'il est
quasiment certain de voir augmenter la
fréquentation de son restaurant
ça fait démarrer chrono notre saison
tout est écrit ça amène beaucoup plus de
monde donc il ya tous les cours au
charisme ya la famille qui arrive et les
le public qui vient voir cette
manifestation pour l'office du tourisme
du marin c'est une véritable aubaine
un événement comme celui-ci les
retombées économiques sont forcément
présente puisque ce sont les
hébergements c'est de la restauration
ce sont ces le marché couvert avec tous
les artisans se sont également tous les
autres acteurs qui sont sur le même
également autour du marin puisque c'est
quand même 80 des bateaux plus de 80
concurrents sont attendus
mais entre organisateurs sponsors
famille spectateurs ce sont près de 500
personnes qui devraient fréquenter
pendant dix jours les rues du marin